[Music]
not so long ago boris johnson was
promising to drive through an ambitious
u.s uk trade deal
but progress has stalled and now he's
having to take things step by step
what we're wanting to do is make solid
incremental steps on trade
the biden administration is not doing
free trade deals uh around the world
right now but i've got absolutely every
confidence that a great deal is there to
be done and there are plenty of people
in that building behind me who certainly
want to do one
but not if the uk can't resolve the
post-brexit tension over the irish
border the irish peace process important
to many in washington not least this
president president trump said that the
uk was in front of the queue when it
came to a trade deal you seem to have a
different approach is that because of
your
heritage
your concern about
the irish protocol on the deal with the
uk that's
continued to be discussed
but on the protocols i feel very
strongly about those i would not at all
like to see
nor i might add would many of my
republican colleagues like to see
a change in the irish accords
an insurmountable obstacle one
government minister suggesting president
biden doesn't know what he's talking
about
it's a very complicated um uh piece of
agreement the northern ireland protocol
i'm not sure he does uh fully appreciate
all of that we're obviously doing what
we can to help the the u.s government
understand that
but the issue might not be down to a
lack of understanding but rather a lack
of interest
a free trade deal squarely on the agenda
here because boris johnson put it there
ever since the uk voted to leave the eu
in 2016 the prime minister has talked up
the prospect of that u.s uk trade deal
as a big prize of brexit but from the
u.s and presidents biden's perspective
it's quite literally not a big deal the
u.s has other relationships to manage
and more pressing priorities here at
home
ending his time in washington with a
visit to arlington national cemetery a
reminder that despite trade been off the
table for now through our shared history
and shared sacrifice the us and uk have
very deep ties
beth rigby sky news washington